the closing pitch for democrats is the
same as the pitch has always been
you're a bad person if you vote
republican right has nothing to do with
republican policies
it has nothing to do with why joe biden
will be better for the country
it has to do with you you on a personal
level you
yeah you bob you're a bad person if you
vote for donald trump
if don lemon is making this case overtly
in the media you must be delusional to
vote for
donald trump says don lemon over tienen
in fact he says i'm getting rid of trump
voters in my life
there are people who i like hard from
voters i can't have them in my life
because they're so delusional
here is don lemon on cnn saying the
quiet part out loud about what the
democratic agenda really is which is to
close the overton window to the point
where you no longer are allowed in
polite society
if you have conversations that differ
from the mainstream
i have many people who i love in my life
and yeah i come from a red state have
lived in several red states
there are a lot of friends who i had to
really get rid of because they
they are so nonsensical when it comes to
this issue they have the whole every
single talking point that they hear on
state tv
and that they hear from this president
they repeat it and they are blinded by
it
i just i had to get rid of a lot of
people in my life because sometimes you
just have to let them go i think that
they have to
hit rock bottom like an addict right and
they have to want to get help
they have to want to know the truth they
have to want to live in reality they
have to want to be responsible
so a long time ago alexis de tocqueville
who is still the greatest observer of
america in american life
he wrote back in the 1840s and he was
writing about touring the united states
of america
and alexis de tocqueville talked about
the
big problem in american life he said one
of the big problems is that
social sanctions when used can be
extraordinarily powerful
he says that the mob could allow freedom
of thought thought technically
but only to an extent right here's the
tocqueville again writing
nearly two centuries ago the person who
says they are for freedom of thought but
in favor of social stricture of
mainstream opinion
he says quote you are free to think
differently from me and to retain your
life your property and all that you
possess
but if such be your determination you're
henceforth an alien among your people
you may retain your civil rights but
they will be useless to you for you will
be never chosen by your fellow citizens
if you solicit their suffrages and they
will effect to scorn you if you solicit
their esteem
you will remain among men but you will
be deprived of the rights of mankind
your fellow creatures will shun you like
an impure being
and those who are most persuaded of your
innocence will abandon you too unless
they should be shunned in their turn
go in peace i have given you your life
but it is it is
in existence and incomparably worse than
death
the majority lives in the perpetual
practice of self-applause and there are
certain truths which the americans can
only learn from strangers or from
experience
right so the idea here is again that
social structure is one way that
politics is done the left
knows this the left knows this and so
they've decided that they are going to
excoriate anybody who votes differently
than they do and you see this
in nearly every arena of american life
it's why it feels like the country is
falling apart
it used to be that you would get
together with somebody and you go to a
baseball game
and at the baseball game you put your
politics aside because there was a
baseline recognition that you were both
americans
and that while you may have different
political priorities in terms of how you
vote
you still want what's best for america
you still believe in traditional
american values
that has gone by the wayside people on
the left refuse to acknowledge this
people on the right they literally
refuse to acknowledge it
if you vote for donald trump it is
because you are a racist it is not in
spite of the
you're not voting trump to stop the
predations of the left you're voting
trump because you buy into the worst
excesses
of donald trump the reason it's because
you love it you love it you're a bad
person if you vote a particular way
right this is why jonathan chait
supposedly open-minded liberal
he calls charlie cook editor-in-chief of
national review and me he says we are
we are racist because charlie is
considering voting for trump and because
i've said i will vote for trump
and this is how they feel about you
right this is why maisie hirono
yesterday
suggested that 40 percent of americans
are awful people
amazing hirono again she's the dumb
dumbest member of the democratic party
but in her stupidity she speaks truth
yesterday
here is what she had to say about 40 of
the american people this is the final
democratic pitch because the idea is do
you want to be part of that 40
of people no i didn't think so didn't
think so right here's maisie hirono
yesterday saying 40
of the country 40 four in ten americans
are angry resentful and fearful
this is the actual closing pitch put
aside all the policy stuff put aside the
donald trump is bad stuff the reason
they hate trump is not because they hate
trump so much it's because they hate
everybody who would possibly vote for
trump or think of voting for trump and
trump is just the
brutal and vulgar version of those
people you can't have forty percent or
so the country being
uh so angry that they will continue to
vote for somebody like trump who will do
absolutely nothing to improve their
lives
right but he speaks to their anger
resentments and
fear of people like you and me
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content